[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two live long friends talk about
life for a long time I'm link and I'm
red this week at the round table of dim
lighting we are discussing friendships
and to be specific uh the friendships of
men with men
yeah
um we're two of those
we're guys we are men friends who are
who are friends and um
you know it's uh
there's a gen there's a lot of
generalities here and so we'll like
we'll couch that but you know it's um
I'm curious how much we fall into guy
tropes
guy friendship tropes and how much we
subvert or expand Beyond those it's
funny you should ask that link
um yeah I'll go ahead and I'll go ahead
and get the disclaimer right now since
we're getting started and we've already
said the friendships of men which might
right from the top seem uh like it's not
very inclusive so I want to discuss that
and um
I think that today's discussion of
friendship will be potentially helpful
to you
regardless of where you land on the the
Gendron the Gendron which is the gender
Spectrum I call it the gingrum the Gin
drum I'm trying to you know just sort of
like I said get more efficient in my
language trendy that's a trendy term
um well the correct word is Gendron so
uh however we're going to be uh talking
about what a bunch of research has shown
about the differences between the
friendships of men and the difference in
the friendships of women and one of the
reasons the research has shown the
differences between men and women's
friendships is because
traditionally these Studies have divided
people into the binary of men and women
and looked at the differences and so as
Jenna was pointing out a second ago when
we were talking before we got started
you know there hasn't been there haven't
been a lot of studies that are
specifically identifying non-binary
people of people along the gender
spectrum and including that that's
beginning to happen more so we'll have
more insight right but what we have
found in sort of dividing people into
that binary is that there are
differences that for a myriad of reasons
sort of nestle on each side of the
spectrum we do kind of observe certain
things happening on this side of the
spectrum and other things happening on
this side of the spectrum and they're
really interesting differences and so I
think that
um they can they can sort of be
Illuminating and insightful regardless
of where you're at on it and also yes I
think that in looking at what these
Studies have shown
I do think that we fall into some of
these tropes but then I think there's
some of these tropes that we have kind
of defied okay and the reason why we
decided to talk about this is because
it's just another facet of what we found
ourselves
exploring in our latest Rhett and Link
Channel video
where we experience 1984 the year that
we first met and we construct a
scavenger hunt mixed in with a music
video
um that ends with us reclaiming the
recess that we never had when we first
met
um but yeah in the lyrics of the song
We're alluding to some of these
generalities of uh like how guys relate
to each other or at least the the Trope
of that so we will get into some of that
but
um
watch the video you know watch it again
please if you've already watched it
please watch 1984 on the rent link
Channel watch all the videos we're
putting out over there we're very
excited about it
but yeah I think I think these studies
is just a good backbone to then talk
about our own experiences and our own
feelings about
relationships
uh friendship and Jenna is present and
Jenna is a woman
uh and Jenna may have a perspective on
this you do you have a perspective on
friendship Jenna
I I believe I do I do have quite a few
decade law decade plus long friendships
with other women okay so we'll see if if
compare and contrast yeah where are
these things might line up so yep let's
start with I think the thing that would
be uh again as you mentioned these are
General observations right and it's
always uh it's usually a mistake to take
a general observation and then try to
apply it to a specific person because
that specific person
may or may not line up with the general
observation this is when we look at
populations of people groups of people
we send to Tennessee Trends and so don't
think any of this is like well if you're
a man or you're a woman or neither these
things do or don't apply to you that's
not what this is about
but I think this is pretty tropish
studies generally find that women on
average
have higher emotional literacy than men
which includes emotional recognition
understanding management and expression
and these are some of the ways that that
plays out in a friendship I'm just going
to read some of the some of the research
here so I will reference the studies at
at certain times you might get tired of
hearing it but a study titled gender and
friendship why are men's best same-sex
friendships less intimate and supportive
um published in the Personality and
Social Psychology uh bulletin in 2011
found that women's friendships often
involve more emotional sharing and
self-disclosure compared to men's
friendships I'm going to read all these
little little things that are all
related and we can discuss okay yeah
um men's friendships often involve less
emotional intimacy compared to women's
friendships despite men Desiring similar
emotional intimacy from their
friendships they are uh less likely to
actually achieve this intimacy due to
fears of appearing feminine or gay hence
the lyric we're not queer but we're
supportive from our song we were kind of
playing into that that's from a 2015
study men and masculinities and also
men's friendships May provide less
emotional and practical support compared
to women's friendships as per a study in
the Journal of Social and personal
relationships in 2009. okay again these
are things that you might if you if you
were just like spitballing differences
between men's and women's friendships
you might say that women seem to be more
in tune emotionally with their friends
than than men I think we can even start
with like the lyrics of the song like
playing off of the whole using physical
maps in the video you say you are here
and then the other guy says and I'm here
for it here for it you know it just
saying you know what I
enjoy our friendship I'm here for our
friendship I I show up for it I look
forward to it I'm engaged here to
actually say
that it to me it's it there's a barrier
to even saying that
you know even before you get to saying
other things is just expressing
um and appreciation and of like valuing
a friendship is
it it might feel a little awkward it's
just not the type of thing that you know
a lot of people find themselves sane and
I and I think this study is saying that
um guys in general
are less likely to say it and
I relate to that you know it because it
just feels like
you're saying you're getting sappy
you know you're you're expressing
emotion you're expressing care for a
friend and it's just not it's not the
type of thing that
you find yourself doing there's like
some things to overcome but that it we
kind of backed into this place when we
were I was like there's something about
like that that place on the map like we
were writing a song about Maps really is
what I thought we were doing and then it
was like the you are here-ness of it and
being here for it like oh there's
something there and then that that felt
like a breakthrough in the song and then
for me at that moment we were like you
are here and I'm here for it was oh now
this song
is about
our friendship and queer rhymes with
here
yeah and then the next and literally it
was we're not queer
but we're supportive yeah yeah and when
yeah when you came up with that rhyming
prayer was like oh that's that's it
that's it it's one of those things where
it's like the comedy
was sort of leading but then it was so
on theme that we were like yeah this is
and I think this is a uh specifically as
it relates to us
um
lots of people uh think or insist on the
fact that we are actually in a secret
gay relationship right and I think that
this is actually yeah
um
I actually think that this is a symptom
of the way that male friendships
manifest right I think that the reason
that people will be like well those guys
must be gay
uh is is actually just an indication
that well there's something sort of
broken with male friendships in general
so yeah oh well if you're if you're
together all the time if you're talking
you're sharing life in this way you guys
have worked together forever if you
celebrate your gay if you celebrate a
connection then it must yeah it has it
has to be romantic right whereas people
would be much likely to much less likely
to make that accusation not that being
gay as an act I mean in this situation
it feels negative but no it's just like
we're not gay but people think that we
are you wouldn't necessarily do that
with two women that have been in a
friendship for a long time in fact if my
wife says you know if my wife is talking
to somebody else and she says my
girlfriend said so and so so and so
there's a moment where people are like
she's talking about
a partner or is she talking about just
but I never have referred to you as my
boyfriend men don't refer to their
boyfriends as boyfriends if I if a man
says this is my boyfriend you just
assume that he's talking about his
romantic partner
again and again that's a problem we're
not getting We're not gonna get into the
like what part of this is biological and
what part of this is cultural the fact
is is that
um we are all kind of uh subject to the
culture and the norms and they're being
redefined and and helpful ways but you
can't help that you were if you were
born and raised in this atmosphere where
for whatever reason men
have a reputation and I actually think
uh it is a reality have are not as
emotionally available to one another
even if they want to be they have a
tougher time
being emotionally emotionally available
in disclosing things I mean talks these
studies talk about not the just the
self-disclosure they have less
self-disclosure less right sharing yeah
of the what's happening emotionally I
remember back in grade school I looked
over a couple of guys shoulders
including Zach
and there was this trend of making a
list of your friends oh
and these were these were guys that I
remember doing this and it was
um you know well where am I at on Zach's
list where where would he be on my list
where can I make a list because I wasn't
making a list I'm just seeing if I'm on
other people's list did you make a list
do you remember this this list happening
back in grade school I remember these
are my best friends I remember more of
the girls doing I didn't remember seeing
any guys do it but I guess I wasn't
looking over exact shoulder I think I
was on I was on Zach's list but I was
kind of low
well you know and that's I mean I think
that's accurate in Bowie's Creek you get
to like seven or eight and you run out
of people well that might have been five
okay number six this is lower half
um obviously you would have been very
high on my list if not you know and if
not not number one at the
yeah I mean sometimes what grade are we
talking about
this might be second grade or second
grade we were in a different class right
out of sight out of mind I decided
um we were always on each other's list
in practically at the top of the list
but I don't even think I actually made
it but it was interesting that at that
age we felt like a little bit there was
some permission to do that and then at a
certain point it's like yeah you might
know that
the the in our friend group growing up
we were the tightest especially when you
get to uh high school that's when we
started getting the
there was the rumors of being gay and I
think it's just you know people guys are
missing out on expressing
how much they value
uh relations do you remember how do you
remember how intense that rumor got uh
I've kind of totally forgotten about
this but there was a guy
I'd forgot about it entirely I know you
mentioned it on your biscuit like a year
ago or I'll mention it again because
everybody listens to every episode no no
no uh I can't remember his name and of
course this is at a time where
culturally it was very different
specifically where we were at it was
very different and specifically what we
believed in the world view that we were
operating under which is that being gay
was wrong and not just wrong but it was
like shameful and the worst thing that
you could have somebody could accuse you
of right it was you know sadly yes
that's the culture that we were in
and
I think that this guy was writing it
this is his freshman year he was writing
Rhett and Link are gay in multiple
places around the school
and I could and I found out who it was
and confronted him
and I wasn't I'm a lover I'm not a
fighter
I don't come in with a with fisticuffs
as they say I come in with like hey bro
let's talk about this
and uh but I I don't know who it was I
can't even remember the dude's name oh
really okay so it was
I think his first name was started with
a D
okay I can't remember his last name
and uh and that's not the dick joke
and then if you thought that that would
have been a dumb it would have been a
bad bad dick joke
um and he ended up
he had to go to the principal's office
I don't know why I don't I don't
remember the principal's office at all
but if I haven't thought about it maybe
I never saw last time I talked about it
on your biscuits but yeah that was uh so
that accusation has been around for
quite a quite a long time because when
two guys
spend as much time together as we always
did yeah and not just spending time
together like
we'll talk a little bit about this in a
second about sort of the the nature of
male friendships as they they relate to
activities but we did a lot of stuff
together and it was like well if uh
they're gonna be there's a talent show
thing well Rhett link are going to be up
there doing this thing together like oh
there's a there's a a lip sync contest
at the dance
run link gonna be DJ Jazzy Jeff for the
fresh prince you know oh yeah uh and so
we we came into high school with that
kind of mentality they were like yeah we
were peas in a pot we hang out all the
time attached at the hip and that was
the and also sexual partners I will say
I will say that we did not do ourselves
any favors we came in pretty hot to
freshman year if you don't recall when
within two weeks of starting school we
were both dating
two of what were considered you know
back when they used to rank the girls in
in high school which horrible practice
but at harness Central High School the
the the ranking of the hottest girls
included we got two of the top five
according to every everyone at school
who were older than us in our freshman
year and this was a huge upset for me I
mean like I you did that that kind of
expected didn't that clarify things no
but I think that like it made this guy a
little bit he was you know he was a
friend of one of them
and uh he was older than us as well and
it's like these two booze Creek boys
come in they're hanging out all the time
they're dating the hottest girls they
must be gay
or we we need to we need to establish
that anyway my high school started
strong didn't end as well um so I'm not
saying anything about my prowess I'm
just saying it's okay it's a good start
say
Rhett's my best friend
or we're best friends
but to say to the other person
I value our friendship like I care about
you and you know I think we'll get into
you know get into more of the emotional
stuff with like the next study right so
like talk about the like the L word
um but yeah it wasn't it wasn't
something that we did it's something
that
given the trajectory of our friendship
and our career and kind of building our
career on our friendship
you know there's been this journey of of
exploring every aspect of it we're doing
it again right now that I think has
opened us up
um to levels of appreciation that
I think otherwise it would have been
really hard to get here and there's a I
think if your friends guys don't get to
that point if your friendship with
someone is one of the calling cards of
your your brand which you make a living
through and you've kind of built a
company around now first of all that's
fraught with its own issues right of
navigating navigating that but it's also
very good for making sure that you are
talking to each other and even as part
of your brand you're talking about your
relationship
and I yeah I I think about I'd like I
don't have any other friendships where
that is the case I have close
friendships and I have friendships like
I have friendships with guys that
there's an emotional intimacy that can
immediately pick up where it left off
even if like we haven't talked for
months it'd be like oh there's not any
awkwardness I'm going to ask you how
you're how you're doing I'm going to ask
you about your house fatherhood how's
your marriage how's your job like it
gets intimate very quickly because
that's the nature of those friendships
yeah but
it's I mean it's a different thing when
it's it yeah you've got it kind of built
into the structure of your schedule
for the average guy who doesn't have
that
it happens through what we're going to
talk about next which is shared
activities which it creates this right
which is what a lot of male friendships
are based on but before we get into that
um we're going to promote yeah I want a
comedy special the stand-up comedy
special yes over on the mythical Society
you know we've got a bunch of people
here in mythical who are very funny very
talented and
have specific experience with stand-up
comedy and we put together a little
special
uh for a little crowd of mythical folk
and and exclusively for you if you're a
society so you can watch that on the
society uh it's gonna so if you're
listening to this audio the data that
comes out it's going to be Wednesday
June 7th if you're watching this well
today or anytime after you can go over
there and watch it it's already out and
let me tell you
um it exceeded my expectations which
were not low
lots of good laughs in his first second
and third degree this is available for
all members of the society so go over
there mythical society.com
watch this the comedy special
so what's the what's the next study talk
about okay there's a few but this is all
about friendship maintenance
and shared activity so
a study in 2006 the glass partition
obstacles to cross-sex friendships at
work
published in human relations
suggests that women may put more effort
into maintaining friendships often
through communication and mutual sharing
whereas men's friendships may be more
reliant on shared activities
and then another study men's friendships
are more often based around shared
activities like sports or hobbyist
according to studies like gender
differences and friendship patterns
1996. so again if you got you got this
generalization that if you see a group
of
women in a circle and you see a group of
men in a circle you can guess what
they're talking about
this much more likely that women are
talking about they're connecting and the
men are just saying what are we going to
do
or they're talking about a shared
interest
Sports in in for for like a guy standing
around a grill and talk about the meat
stereotypical male
um I mean I you know I've said this
before that like one of the things
you know I would say that if you're
doing a percentage breakdown of my
conversations with my dad
my text thread with my dad a very high
percentage of that is sports related
because I know the kinds of sports
events that he watches
that I also watch and I'm like this is
happening right now he's probably
watching this if I text him we are
currently experiencing the same thing
um which is and we're connecting uh over
that yeah in some ways it ends up being
this thing that like oh you know
men really just want to be the you know
the joke is men really just want to be
intimate with one another
uh and self-disclose and be around one
another but the only way that they could
do that is direct all that passion and
that energy towards a guy with a ball
who's not either one of them
do you know what I'm saying and it's
just like we got all this energy we just
want to hug each other but we want to
watch that guy slam that guy and that's
how we're going to
experience it
I mean
definitely the doing of things
it just seems like it's the it's just
the default we're gonna what are we
gonna do let's do something
let's um
let's let's go for a hike I mean we
actually we were talking even a few you
know a few minutes ago it's like okay
well let's let's plan something should
we go let's go surfing again it's been a
long time since we've been surfing
um
and it's just it's kind of an easy way
to then know that you're gonna you're
gonna connect but it's like work we're
doing something shoulder to shoulder it
might be watching something or walking
towards something or surfing towards
something but it's
it's a lot easier to then find the
connection along the way
it feels but it's also easier sitting
down and just staring at each other like
but it's also easier to not connect too
it is so it it's like again you're
together and this common interest is
brought you together and I would say
that
a lot of guys
have a friend who is there blank fill in
the blank friend
he's my goth my golf buddy yeah my poker
buddy the the whatever and so it says
like this guy falls into this category
because I do this thing
with him
whereas if we're not like I don't know
what I'd do if we weren't playing golf
and you know I think thankfully I think
that this is my guess is that this is
um this is also a generational thing I I
would suspect that
guys in their 20s this is not nearly as
much the case as it is for guys in their
40s or guys older than us like the older
you are the more you are kind of
associated with an older generation the
more this is probably the case because
things are shifting and kind of opening
up yeah and it's becoming you know these
stereotypes
are kind of being revealed as being sort
of in many ways sort of a result of
these cultural norms that have been
reinforced and people are
having their way with those and breaking
them open yeah
in the same way so I like where the
where the trends and women can just play
golf together
just for the sake of playing golf I mean
Jenna do you how do you feel about these
generalities when it comes to like guys
just like to do stuff together and women
just get together and just weep
said that that's what women do when they
get together is they just no I was
joking but more there's like more of a
perm
permission to uh
connect emotionally and to share
thoughts and feelings self-disclosure as
we talked about I will say because I I
have those friends that I are kind of
categorized in the things I do with them
like I have my Universal
um annual pass friends okay who we
always we always go to the park together
and that's where we catch up but like as
that's how we started but as are like
friendships evolved like we get together
outside of the park now and we check in
on each other it's not all about
Universal like we have a text thread
that's not all about like Universal
stuff it's about like other life things
as well so I think like that yeah yes to
the activities but I feel like that's
what you all do as well you have the
activities but you also talk about life
when you do those things yeah yeah
definitely I mean I have a text thread
with
um
my dad friends and it but it's mostly
the text thread is just what planning
the next thing
you know one thing and our College
friends that text thread is planning the
next thing which may be a phone call and
now but there's not a lot of like to our
credit and I will say that with the
college buddies we haven't been great
about the frequency lately as everyone's
lives have gotten back to normal but
during the pandemic we started a regular
connection that was again it was about
disconnecting and because everybody in
that group is an emotionally mature guy
who understands the benefit of that type
of interaction and that sort of intimacy
and interestingly I think a lot of that
came from our background
in church but also the specific type of
Ministry that we were involved in with
like crew crew you know campus Crusade
there was a lot of there was a lot of
sharing in circles yeah yeah you you get
to like literal circles you get together
with a group mostly it's divided by
gender at least it was a crusade so it's
like you got a guy Bible study you got a
girl Bible study
uh
and unlike those heathens and
intervarsity that put the guys and the
girls together what were they thinking
um
but you you got pretty good at being
honest and like disclosing and having
those conversations so I think a lot of
that with those guys because we all got
to know each other in that environment
it's kind of based on that level of
intimacy which was a little bit of a
weird sort of like benefit that we got
we don't agree with everything that we
learn in that setting but there were
some life skills that we referenced
quite often but to me it's about your
phone calls right
and again I'm just talking about my wife
my beautiful wife Jesse
uh who makes phone calls to people and
the purpose of the phone call
is the phone call
yeah okay okay okay
I
and I'm I never do that if I call you I
have a reason the phone call
is serving
and I don't and I just I'm not saying I
do this on purpose I don't calculate
this I'm just saying and I probably
should just call people to catch up but
it's always even when it is just to
catch up it is precipitated by an event
like it's their birthday you know what
I'm saying yeah how you doing it's your
happy birthday
let me talk to you and figure out how
you're doing now but
no calls out of the blue and I'm not
this makes me not as good of a friend I
will freely admit that that a good
friend I think will call you and just
catch up
but it's just not in me naturally to be
like I'm gonna call this person to
connect whereas every time I hear my
wife talking to someone on the phone it
seems like the only purpose is to
connect
you know what I'm saying she's not yeah
I don't do that I mean I I'll call but
it's I mean it's usually now it's just
like a text to like well let's get
coffee
you know I want to catch up but like I
I don't consider the the phone like a
viable option for that like it's got to
be I gotta go a step further I gotta
there's gotta be
a coffee involved or grabbing a beer
Jenna you call people just to talk no I
I am I am also horrible about this I'll
do it with like a very select few like a
couple family members and like one or
two friends but usually there's some
other like I need their advice on
something and that's why I'm caught like
it's not just to call or like I haven't
seen my niece in a while I want to see
my niece which I guess is like a a just
because call but yeah I don't do that at
all and I have friends who do that
constantly like my best friend has
friends of hers that will call her every
single day just to and I think it's
crazy I think it's I'm like that's a lot
you just talked yesterday and like yeah
so I think that's too much for me but
like the relationship I have with my
best friend like her and I don't have
that like we we see each other
constantly because we also live together
so it's like I'm not gonna just call her
out of the blue for no reason anyway I'm
gonna go in this other room to call you
but like she she has like many friends
who will call on a regular basis and she
will call on a regular basis just to
chat and I'm like we are not the same
person I cannot do this well and then
you know you talked about the L word I
just we could talk about that a bit it
kind of ties these first two things in
together
you know the ultimate emotional
disclosure just saying that you love
somebody Jesse ends
70 of her conversations with I love you
and so that's meaningless no no like
Jesse you know will talk to someone who
uh
he works for her at Jesse Lane Interiors
and in the conversation with I love you
I mean I I think it's wonderful and
beautiful but it is so different than
the way I like
okay so back to our song I've never told
an employee that I that I love him back
to our song because the lyric is like a
brother from another mother but I won't
tell you I love you because that might
make it weird weird rhymes with queer
and here again it's the rhyme
leads us because it will yeah if it's
like I love you you know it's just like
it's it's just that's it's weird out of
the blue I mean there's people like I
talked to Dad on dispatches about you
know you know there's people who wrote
him emails about how
we end every podcast saying that we love
each other yeah which is what we do on a
phone call
um
but there's a lot of people who
um they don't have that with their
parent and it's I just chalk that up to
if
if you don't do it from like if you
don't establish that that's part of
something that you do then it's hard to
start doing it at a later date yeah it
was it was not uh it was not commonplace
okay in my household growing up I felt a
lot of love and I was shown a lot of
love and
both of my parents would say I love you
in certain contexts but as a way to say
goodbye
that wasn't just it just wasn't a part
of the way that we talked to each other
so there wasn't an I love you
at the end of a phone conversation once
I was in college however at some point
as adulthood set in especially once we
moved out here and now we're like in a
different place and there's much less
interaction we lived in the same town or
like right you know very close to each
other it was different
regularly say I love you to end a
conversation with either of my parents
or my brother at this point but I think
that's also a function of the fact that
we
like our our as our friend group
developed when we got to LA
we made friends with people who said I
love you
at the end of a like hanging out
yeah there were a few of those other
dudes that you would like hug when they
showed up and hug when they left and you
say I love you and I was kind of like or
it might be love you man yeah yeah yeah
if you add a yeah and a man right then
it's kind of like that couches it a
little bit yes and that's then but
that's that's still something but we and
we've talked about this before this is
where it gets a little bit weird with us
yeah because we share many of the same
friends
and we have these gatherings where okay
like okay there's a guy you don't love
as much as you love me by telling that
you love him because he told you he
loved you let's talk we'll talk about
what about me so Mike is our mutual
really good friend of ours
and you may know him as science Mike and
you know Mike said a lot of the things
that we together that we would do and
that's the kind of relationship we have
with Mike it's very there's a it's
hugging it's saying I love you and then
like I'll like be hugging him by saying
I love you and like your people there
you are you do the same thing to him
right and then it's like well I guess
the next logical step is for Rhett and
Link right to hug and say I love you but
we go like we may do it but like it's
sort of this like oh let's be funny
about it a little silly because this is
like I'm gonna see you at 8am
you know what I'm saying like and and
it's not
yeah it's just not something that we
ever did so like is there ever a point
when
we we'd have to make a decision to
change
like
I think the first times that we said I
love you to each other we're like in the
context of a video where it was like
I think so
I think on GMM or something where it was
just it might be true and it was for the
comedy of it but the comedy was like
yeah we never actually say this to each
other there's no doubt that we do love
each other but it's it's that brotherly
thing of like
I mean you had to make a decision to
start saying telling Cole that you love
him yep and that was an adult decision
mm-hmm right
um
calls my brother I'm not defending
I'm just trying to I'm just trying to
explain a little bit it isn't it's an
interesting Dynamic I think that there's
um
yeah there's a there's a lot there's
friends that I've made now that as an
adult that are more emotionally
connected to themselves and and will sit
in a more comfortable saying
I miss you I haven't talked to you in a
while or I you know I had a friend text
me and we were talking about getting
together and I'm like on this Le
when you want to hang it let's hang out
and then
he he was like yeah I I really miss your
energy is what he told me and I was like
man that made me feel good but that's
not something that I said to him
but it's something that it was what was
behind me initiating the text the to
like say hey
how are you how are you doing let let's
hang out
and then but the truth of it was hey man
I really value our friendship and I'm I
miss your energy let's get together but
it's a
it's a way of speaking that just like
wearing your heart on your sleeve I'm a
fan of that I I feel like I do that
I do a decent job of that at certain
times but I still have to make up my
mind to do it
and I'm inspired by when I receive
that level of openness from another guy
friend especially
it's like oh I note that like maybe
maybe I can change maybe I can be that
person who puts myself out there a
little bit more and say
um
I'm I miss I miss hanging out it's been
too long
I miss you because like saying that is
is just as hard as saying I love you
almost maybe you know yeah I think for
me
there's two things the vulnerability to
it I think there one thing doesn't fall
in a masculine column is that I am um
would definitely an introvert when it
comes to like where I get my energy from
I get it from being alone
and so like okay I
um
I love being with people I love being in
groups of people and I have a really
good time and obviously
introversion and extroversion is really
just a framework to understand
you know people and I think that it is
best explained as where you kind of get
recharged is it with someone or not with
something it's not really like your
personality characteristics because
obviously I'm comfortable in a group and
I I look people in the eye and you know
it's it's
I can be outgoing in other words
and comfortable in a group or with in
conversation but you don't find yourself
Desiring yeah most of the time I find
myself Desiring to be alone
and like be doing something
where I kind of get lost and thought or
I listen to something or I just yeah
that so for me I have to make an effort
to be like oh there's value in this
yeah I said there's not a natural
tendency to be like I don't sit around
and think oh I miss filling the blank
and I need to spend some time with him
like it's like it just doesn't that's
not how I think about it I think more
about an activity like I would love to
do this and that person would be great
to do that with yeah that's one thing
and then I think another thing is that
I mean I think it's important to give
yourself Grace in this area because
or anybody anybody okay and you included
um because I think there's truth to what
you just said which is like can I be
more of whatever it is be more available
be more vulnerable be more expressive
and I do think that there's yes because
you don't I'm not trying to make an
excuse of like well everyone's different
and everyone expresses things
differently but what but one of the
things that I have found is because I am
um I'm not super expressive when it
comes to to these things
but because that's my base level
sort of way of being when I make a
decision to be expressive or to say
something it carries a lot of weight and
so for me I find myself thinking like
okay well I am this way for some reason
I'm continuing to try to get more in
touch with myself through therapy
I want to be more available to people
and I'm continuing to work on that in
the meantime one of the benefits of that
is that
these things carry you kind of a lot of
weight given the nature of my
personality it's like there's a weakness
that can become a strength at times
whereas you might have somebody who's
sharing all the time and there's a
benefit and a strength in that because
you can feel super supported by them all
the time but it's almost like
cursing you know I I've tried to explain
this to my kids if I feel like you're I
hear you cursing too much and it's not
that I think there's a problem with
cursing I think that cursing is a very
handy linguistic tool for emphasis
and I think you want to keep it special
so you can use it at the right [__]
moment
that wasn't it to make a point so anyway
I'm just saying that's so I'm just
saying that I
that's one of the that's one of the ways
that I give myself some some Grace in
this because
I think that there are people that this
would come more naturally to and it's
and it does and it does come more
naturally
to them and so I think that there's sort
of like a there's a framework of
or there's a patchwork of people and
it's like well this person I experienced
in this way and I and I like that I'm
not saying this is an excuse to stay
closed off I'm just saying this is a way
of giving yourself Grace as you grow
this is what but I'm talking about
something a little different okay I I
think I'm not talking about Conjuring up
feelings you don't have I'm talking
about
expressing feelings that you do have I'm
not talking about you I'm talking about
me I'm talking in general that if I
notice that I miss somebody I haven't
seen so and so in a while yeah I want to
go
um I want to see I want to see him
and then what I haven't done is said
that
haven't said you know what it's been two
I'm I miss you like that phrase is very
vulnerable
and it and it it almost feels like it
carries
you know it's it really it's putting
yourself out there one of the things
that so but I that's what I'm trying to
do more of is I've actually been in a
phase you talk about like introversion
extroversion
um coming out of the pandemic is that's
what I thought it was related to
um and maybe it still is but
cultivating
some friendships like I've I've met
a handful a smattering of new people
over the past couple of years and some
of them are some of them know each other
some of them don't
and um
I've
prioritized like cultivating those
relationships being the one to initiate
and say hey let's get together
um let's hang out
it's been a while let's catch up you
know and
um some of those people are like they're
just totally responsive and maybe you
would fall more into that camp in the
way that you describe like
um I'm friend with this this guy who's
more I I think he's more introverted
like I'm still getting to know him but
like every time I initiate he's always
game and he's always like here's a
couple of days let's make this happen
and then even to the point where it's
like
uh
I was like I can do Thursday or Friday
and he's like I'll keep both of them
open it's like okay this guy never
initiates with me but he's always
responsive so that tells me that he
values our friendship especially when he
says I'm Gonna Keep two days open
when so that we can make sure this
happens like
to me those are little those are things
that I noticed that was like oh this
he's reciprocating in his own way and
with with another new friend that I made
he's the guy who's more like I miss your
energy like he's he's the one who's
uh we initiate about the same
um but he's he puts him he puts his
emotions out there and he's more
vulnerable and that encourages me to do
that too and that there's there's
there's some reward there you know
that's like okay I know where I know
where we stand and it's not just we're
not speaking in code
um about well is is this really just
about golfing you know
um
because when I get together with people
I do want to connect
like I like connecting with a person I
like getting to know them it's not you
know
it with both of those relationships it
started out with we we're both
interested in the same thing
um a lot of times it's music so it's
like let's get together and listen to
music you know
um
that actually is a big factor in both of
those friendships because it's another
thing that I've really I've really
identified a passion and like putting
those two things together I love
connecting with making friends deepening
friendships and I love music and if I
can find people that that's really the
beginning of our relationship
then that's that's a good one-two punch
that's um but then yeah I've talked
about Nick my mountain biking friend
it's like whenever a mountain biking it
is an occasion for us to talk about
other things but like we pretty much
sometimes there might be a camping trip
occasionally or an off-roading trip in
the past but like it is pretty much
relegated to that but then within that
there's you pick those moments where
it's like oh we're we're we're
connecting interpersonally if not
emotionally I'm sharing some things and
then seeing hey if does he want to
reciprocate where does this where does
this go and so that's it's rewarding uh
what's my point
um what do you hear me saying
um well you're kind of just describing
your experience
um the part about
not Conjuring feelings but expressing
the feelings that you have I think is
is where I'm at in terms of
taking a risk
and and and I'm I'm seeing the rewards
of that that like oh
even texting somebody feels like a risk
sometimes it's like hey do you wanna
do you want to hang out this weekend you
know yeah I think and you put putting
yourself out there
it
it's a hard thing to do
for me but I see the I'm experiencing
the rewards of and it kind of helps me I
I mean I think that
um
there's a there's there's two stages
there's the
um
having the initiative communicating that
you want to well you're kind of talking
about the new the it's not Nuance
there's a difference in like saying I
want to do this thing with you or saying
I miss you there's a difference in those
two things right and if that's the way
that you want to play it I think that's
healthy and good I don't necessarily
think that the guy who says I would like
to play golf with you who actually kind
of means I want to hang out with you I
don't think that there's anything wrong
with that necessarily
it's like well if you want to be hang
with somebody you have to tell them that
you can't tell them that you just want
to play golf no no you're not saying
that no and I'm just clarifying that
you're not saying that
for me it's the uh once I am with
someone
um I don't like I'm I'm an open book I'm
not
um I don't withhold things I'm not like
cold I'm not
um I'll talk about anything with anyone
and I'll get as personal as vulnerable
not as not as vulnerable and as quickly
as my wife
uh but she's she is an exception to the
rule of how quickly you will know her
life story but I'm pretty close behind
her in my willingness to kind of share
and be intimate with somebody even
people that I just meet at a party but
also people in the context of
friendships where I struggle
is
taking the initiative to set up the
situation where that will happen do you
know what I mean yeah so for me it's
like sometimes
Jesse even might say that she'd be like
why don't you call so-and-so
you know like what you want you to why
don't you just call him I want you to
see what he's he's up to or or whatever
if I'm
um like don't have anything going on or
whatever it's not and then my tendency
will be like well
that would be fun but it would kind of
also just be fun to like watch some show
that you don't want to watch with me you
know and I have to you know so I'm not
yeah that the extrovert that could be
overdone for me I have to I have to make
a decision to be like okay I need to
take the initiative here because once
I'm in once I'm in that situation like
if I'm playing golf with somebody
you're there no something you're there
for it it's like I'm not yeah I'm like
I'm playing but I'm also like hey like
let's talk about something else and I
get frustrated when I go into social
situations often with with other guys
and it becomes very clear that they only
are interested in the game that we're
playing
like if you play sometimes you might
play poker with somebody
or the group of guys and it's like
no time for talk man this is about
strategy and it's kind of like oh this
is going to be a little bit boring for
the next three hours yeah or there's no
self-disclosure yeah ever yeah it's like
um yes I'm not into that I just don't I
just need to take the initial and some
people take it like some people take
longer right I I think when it comes to
us one of the things you know as we've
as we've invested in our friendship over
the past year and still made like had
some really good conversations one of
the things that I took from that and
this kind of plays into I think that the
next study that you want to bring up
about
conflict
or whatever it is
I
realized that
um we both
we've we value our shared experiences
and they build into our friendship but
I'm not going to hold it against you if
I'm the one that initiates more often
than you do because
I know that you will be responsive that
you're that you're up for that you've I
don't read into it and say well if if
Rhett really cared about me he would he
would initiate he would come up with a
thing he'd invite me to do the thing
um because of what you've already talked
about
and I know that about you for me it's
like well if I have if I'm if I have
this felt need to for for us to hang out
um
then
I should initiate that
and then the ball's in your court how
you're going to respond and then you've
got a very good track record of being
very up for you know like
I pretty much know they're gonna be like
absolutely you know and now I'm applying
that to other people that I don't know
as well it's like I'm not going to read
into the fact that he never asked to
hang out with me because he is always up
for it when I do initiate and I do so
I I don't think I had a
I I don't have a I don't think I ever
had a chip on my shoulder that like you
I think well
I think there was a time when I was
tempted to have a chip on my shoulder
that like you weren't
coming up with the idea for us to just
hang out as friends or something
and I think part of my growth is the
Insight that like I don't think that I
shouldn't be taking that personally
you know it it wasn't it that didn't
reflect your feelings
the feelings that you had or didn't have
for me because you were always
responsive
um
if I were to initiate that well and I
think that
um there's another aspect of of our
friendship
and
I as you well know am
sort of constantly overwhelmed with all
the things that I think that we should
be doing
yeah professionally right right
um
and I in in a sort of I talked about
this on the solo episode and in the
somewhat potentially pathological
fashion
I'm constantly thinking about work I
never I never stopped thinking about I
mean if I if something is happening to
me
in life I'm I'm taking a note I'm coming
up with an idea like it is a constant
stream waking up in the middle of the
night having a dream waking up like it's
always relates back to my professional
life and how this can be translated into
something that we could do
yeah and put in front of an audience
it's just the way I've always been
and so because we have the things that
we really want to do which is to create
and then we have the things that we have
to do which is
all the logistical things involved with
running a business like this that uh I
think we're pretty good at it but I also
think that it's not the thing that we
want to do like I now I was never
interested in being a boss
never something that I was like I didn't
wake up me I want to be a boss of over
100 people one day like not a childhood
dream no
um I wanted to be a boss in like the
like the 2010 lingo you know you had a
boss okay
um but I just I just wanted to make
things and so when I think about I I
sort of I look at the time that we have
together
in every moment
that we have together I'm just thinking
like what can we do what can we make how
can we fight for this time that we have
to do all the things that I think we
still should do before we die right
we're old we've got to keep doing things
and it's not that I'm like I don't have
time for surfing or skiing or fishing
which we never have done but
um let's go fishing but very quickly as
you know if you go surfing with me well
I'm still gonna talk to you about the
things that it isn't and to be clear
I don't yeah I hope you don't they say
it's not I asked you a lot I asked you
lots of questions about your life and
your kids and I I'm not not interested
in having a personal conversation about
things but because I feel like I've got
this uh
box full of Ambitions that's constantly
overflowing it's just like it's got to
fit in our relationship in our time that
we have to talk to each other which is
in between all the stuff that we have to
do
that I think that
um
sometimes in in the very quick shuffling
that's happening in my brain about
what's the most important thing right
now is it to
um connect or is it to accomplish I'll
too quickly move to accomplish yeah so
it's it's more like
you know I wouldn't do it because I
value my relationship with my wife and
my family but if if if my wife and
family were didn't exist or were robots
that had no feelings
then I would be like hey man let's work
on Saturday and Sunday
I know you would I'm just telling you
that's what I would do because and I'm
saying because it's fun it's fun to me
yeah you know what I'm saying I I'm
doing the activity that brings me the
most Joy it's not surfing brings me a
lot of Joy but in the ranking of
activities creating is more fun than
surfing and so it's like that's my hobby
that's what I want to do that's why I
got a side project that's just creating
something it's just because there's
that's what I want to do right and I
want to do it with you so I think that
that's one of the Dynamics that ends up
don't take that out of context that's
that's one of the Dynamics that
manifests itself in our friendship
right but I'm still going to say all
right let's do something and we can't
talk about work
yeah yeah I appreciate that we can't do
work I think it's important yeah
um
what was the yeah so what was that the
final study well there's
there's multiples I I'm not What's the
conflict Point
um
a study called gender differences in
social Focus among friends in 2009 in
the international Journal of Behavioral
development found that women uh take
conflicts more personally
while men may be more likely to overlook
them I gotta say I mean
that the the the female relationships
that I observe the most are like
Christy and her friends like you know
hearing their conversation I heard
Christie's side of the conversation all
that type of stuff you know it's like I
don't want to throw her under the bus
but like I
like the the Dynamics at play in all of
those relationships are so complicated
compared to what I I feel like I when I
relate to my guy friends and I I feel
like I'm playing into the trophy I don't
have it written right here but it was in
the same study or another one and around
conflict that said that women are more
likely to end a relationship over a
conflict than a minute so interesting
interesting that there's more emotional
disclosure and more intimacy so the the
relationships are deeper which I think
just I think ultimately maybe one thing
about that is it increases the stake so
if a men have a shallower connection
that's based on golf right well you're
gonna get into a fight over like
somebody like you know what I'm saying
so maybe that's why this tends to be a
pattern I feel like I'm like I've never
I've never ended a friendship
well you know I have ever we talked I've
never ended a friendship and ironically
the guy who said I miss you I I then
ended the friendship I mean I had one of
my friends in high school
screwed my girlfriend
and I wasn't even screwing her because I
didn't believe in premarital sex
and I broke up with her
and I don't I'm not proud of this but
like I kind of he was still my friend
and it was like probably wrong I I was
probably but I was kind of like dude you
know yeah
yeah Jenna can you be the judge on this
one
uh or not whatever you want to say I'm
not gonna be a judge on that one
I'm not proud of it I mean maybe I
should have been an [__] to him I I
feel like I'd say it all depends on how
did you treat her the same were you an
[__] to her I wasn't an [__] to
her I was just like I think that this
means that we're breaking up like I've
just I have a you I love to act like I'm
really mad for videos on the internet
and people think that I'm being real but
like I actually have a really difficult
time getting mad I don't remember I
think you were hurt but I don't think
you were mad I never like gonna go in
and like yell at somebody I'm I was just
like
we're breaking up or whatever and then
like I saw him the next day and we both
kind of like
he was like I just couldn't myself to
hate the guy because I was like
well I don't want to pick this scenario
apart what I was asking Jenna about was
this general idea that
um
men
I like well I'll speak for myself I feel
like
if some you know it's like I can I can
slot people in a different categories of
friendship like okay you know what the
more that I get to know this guy the
more that like now he's he's kicking
back out he's not going to be an inner
circle guy he's going to be kicked back
out a little bit and like
and if somebody if somebody if there's a
level of incompatibility or we get our
wires crossed
I just don't find myself in drama I'm
just gonna put it that way it's like
okay this guy
we're not
you know
I won't talk to him as often or I'll see
him as this type of friend not this type
of friend and um I'm not going to share
that information with him anymore but I
just learned my lesson you know it's
like it's like a categorization
compartmentalization of levels of
friendship and I feel like it's because
the bar is so low for guy friendships
that and that the bar is higher in
general for
um female friendships
am I off base in your opinion I don't
think you're off base I think it's a
larger cultural discussion of of women
um being told they they cannot be
confrontational so then when
confrontation does happen it can really
end things
um whereas men can have little
confrontations and those are fine but
like I I don't like confrontation either
I um I uh but I have ended friendships
because things went to a personal level
and I it's how we culturally
have established those relationships
like women already have this strong
bonded emotional thing behind it which I
mean it's cultural but then it's also
it's it can be a bit hormonal as well of
like we have formed those and and I
think it's
I I don't it's hard to say that it's
male or female because I I very much am
um
I I don't get super emotional like like
I I know that friends of mine female
friends of mine
take things to Heart a lot different
than I do and I because I understand
that I I phrase things different and I
speak to them different and
I think that's just a level of growth
and therapy for me instead of like when
I was younger oh we don't we don't Vibe
on this I don't like this person We're
Not Gonna Be Friends yeah period I I
think I might have an analogy that is
helpful because I agree with you that
again we're talking in general
generalities uh in
you know a lot of people's opinion which
I know is it in at least it's it to some
degree true is that a lot of these
generalities exist because of cultural
norms and and things that have been put
on to people
um and so if there is a situation in
which like if you're in a pool and men's
uh relationships more often are in the
shallow end of the pool and women's
relationships are more often in the deep
end of the pool well
you're more likely to drown in the deep
end of the pool right if you if that's
where you're swimming the stakes are
higher and it could result in
um a loss somebody sinks to the bottom
right
there's consequences to getting into a
conflict in the deep end of the pool
where that don't exist in the kiddie
pool and so mistakes for women in
Conflict are a lot there's a lot more
pressure on women for those uh conflicts
that happen than for men like if women
have this conflict happen where dramatic
where
um uh too aggressive we get it labels us
as this type of person that then no one
wants to work with or be around whereas
men can have those same conflicts and
he's just standing up for himself yeah
yeah right and I that totally makes
sense that's helpful
I also think for guys it's just you know
it's
in the shallow pool analogy it's like oh
well
this doesn't matter that much
you know like the level of connection is
just less so I'm just gonna
I'll compartmentalize them or I'll just
uh you know that's that's the end of
that friendship and I didn't even
realize it right right if so if you've
got a guy that you play golf with and he
gets tendonitis
and then it's just like oh I hadn't
talked to Chuck in four years right his
elbow's messed up you know what I'm
saying and it's like it it because it
right it was so basic you wanted
something yeah apparently he wasn't a
true friend he was just a golf buddy um
I wanted to there's a couple of sort of
things that you may not have anticipated
that I wanted to make sure that we
talked about okay close this discussion
which I hope has been helpful I'm sure
um I don't know if it's been helpful but
I mean again it's just like I know we're
kind of we're we're going to each side
of this spectrum and like living there
and I know that that can be irritating
to some people but hopefully because as
Jenna said that like as she has
demonstrated already that like well
in this situation I would actually
behave more like what your studies show
how a man would react again because it's
like these general characteristics don't
apply to individual people they apply to
groups
um
so give us some more so I'll give you
some more General stuff uh virtual
friendship
according to a 2015 Pew Research Center
report uh men are more likely than women
to consider online contacts as friends
so like somebody that is and this is
maybe generational too because like I
don't have in fact someone asked me
recently if I hadn't you were there they
were talking about it was me
oh but we were in a party I didn't
realize you're the one who started that
discussion I think I was
um
do you have people that you're just
friends with online like is there
somebody that a social network friend
and then your wife was like yeah I have
a thread
an Instagram
thread where it's like a text thread but
it's just on Instagram and I'd never met
these people and I was like oh that's
something that can happen like it was
like it was like I don't have anybody
now there may be some people that I've
like
um
there's a few people that are like
public figures that we've connected via
social media like DMS um
but it's not a friendship it's more just
like yes we've sent three messages over
the past four years about specific
things
but it's it's not a friendship that's
maintained online and I definitely don't
see them as a friend yeah I don't relate
to Friendly acquaintance
we're so it's so weird the way that we
experience social media as it was
happening that it was it was
like it's tough to apply as content
creators it kind of short-circuited
actually using it as like for personal
connection we never really saw it that
way as it was developing and then by the
time everybody caught up we were just
these people who were just pumping out
content through these pipelines yeah so
I never we never utilized it that way
yeah we made so it's interesting
thousand Facebook friends for the right
promotional quality of it yes
and then
still have most of them but don't go on
Facebook no
um
a study published in
plos one I guess that's plus one with an
O 2014. sex differences in social Focus
across the life cycle in humans
exciting stuff
suggested that men tend to have larger
but less intimate social networks
compared to women
so
um
more acquainted you started listing
people that you would call your friends
and it's like
I don't know what you know you would
constitute a friend but apparently would
include online friends on average
a man would have more
but they'd be less intimate but it would
be this larger
Network I thought that was an
interesting tidbit I don't think it's
necessarily anything that I relate to
personally yeah I just don't have
capacity for like that's why I broke up
with that guy who said he missed me
because I I've you know I went through
the whole thing when it happened on on
the show but I didn't feel like I had
the capacity to give him what I felt
like I I wanted to give to be an actual
friend
and it was like I remember one time of
actually breaking up with her yeah I
learned my lesson
um and I got so I I don't I don't do
that anymore I've had friendships end
but it was because of uh complex social
dynamics amongst groups and couples and
stuff like that yeah but never I haven't
had a situation where there was a guy
that I was a friend with and then
something that he did
to me or to someone else
it was like now I have to end the
Friendship that's never happened and
again as I suggested it would take a
whole lot
based on what happened in high school
yeah I'm not saying it's a healthy thing
I mean maybe I should have ended more
friendships but it just hasn't crossed
my mind and lastly and this is something
we can relate to because we are both
aging
aged
um
study published in the journal personal
relationships in 2017.
said or found that men may have fewer
friends as they grow older due to
Reliance on their partners for emotional
support
I actually think that uh so you're
you've already described how you are
like personally bucking this trend
to be making an effort there yeah
um
it's not something that I have been
doing
um
I
have a fair amount of friends
I don't have too many friends that I
talk to on a regular basis that we're
like constantly doing stuff with each
other
mostly because it I feel connected
enough right
but I do see how this like let's just
say that
um we had a horrible me and you had a
horrible breakup went our separate ways
uh something that is constantly being
theorized is about to happen just so you
know not only are we gay but we're also
constantly about to break up
right
neither has been true ever but
I can totally see because I have a very
and I think I speak for both of us I
have a very deep emotional bond to my
wife like we
you know we share everything together
we're not isolated we haven't grown I
feel like that's enough we haven't grown
apart as we've gotten older we've grown
together we're better friends now than
we were when we were youngsters
I get a lot out of our friendship and
our time together we like spending time
together we like doing things together
like we like traveling with one another
and so I could see how this would be the
case where I would just kind of be like
ah I don't
you know as long as I got her um I'm all
right I I like being by myself and
apparently the study you know studies
show that this is actually a pattern it
probably I mean I'm sure this goes both
ways as you get older like as you're in
a couple
of any description and you kind of just
like I got this person and it's hard to
find time and the conjure up the effort
to connect and then that person dies
okay
and then you're just old and alone yeah
I'm like that is kind of a scary I'm
heading to my bets I'm feeling pretty
good
you know on that front yeah you're
you're you'll have your side number
you're selling some good seats I'm not
talking about Christy dying I'm talking
about you dying but oh yeah um
but I I don't have a replacement for you
but um I think the amalgamation of
um
a bunch of other friends would just keep
me
keep me but if you fast forward into the
distant future you know I'm dead early
because I'm tall whatever it's just you
and Christy right uh she's most likely
gonna outlive you because women on
average live longer than men but let's
just say that there's an accident
okay great and obviously but she's old I
mean you're both in your 80s it's kind
of like yeah she's in an accident it's
kind of like well it's gonna happen one
way or another
and so you're 85 and you're single and
so it puts you in that scenario
uh
uh first of all 85 single you're going
to try to get with somebody but that's
not no it's just sexually let's just
talk about that before we talk that's a
whole other podcast like if you're 85
and you're finally single you're gonna
go to like a dating website what are you
gonna do uh yeah sure you think you have
no no desire to wet your willy at that
point
it's not gonna be about desire I just
hope it's gonna be about ability and I I
hope that there's drugs for that man
right well there you go okay then yes so
yeah so you're gonna get laid at 85.
that's the first few weeks is you just
getting laid as much as possible
foreign
I mean I'm not going to deny it but but
then
comes friendship
okay so my question for you as it
relates to that is um
like what would you do
I I have friends right okay so I'm
working on it now yeah yeah yeah yeah
because I think it's happening at that
point I would join a group of some kind
that was doing something like that we're
planting trees you know
mm-hmm and I feel like let's get
together and read the paper and that
kind in the context of a group like that
that I would definitely do because I'd
have to time you know
um I think I could generate a lot of
friends really quickly so I'm kind of
you can catch up I'm not because
ultimately I was saying yeah don't worry
I'm not worried about it I can make fast
friends when I want to
yeah yeah yeah don't worry about it
just be my friend
I'll be your friend whenever you
whenever you want to do it and then I'll
be friends with other people when you
don't and then everybody's happy I think
this is working right yeah yeah I think
it is I think it is working I think it
is working uh yeah I got plans Friday
night I think I got playing Saturday
night
and um what does your wife say about
this
uh I try to make plans with her first
and then when she Taps out because it's
too many plans then I just fill
everything else in
that's the way I do it
yeah yeah and I don't make plans I've
started making more plans
you know that's my thing yeah I'm not me
I don't I don't make many I'd like to
make more activity plans
um you feel you feel like this is a good
this is a good ending point I'm as good
as any okay
um I want to bring you back to our rent
Link channel for my recommendation
our song you are here is streaming
everywhere so enjoy that song
it's
it makes more sense when you've watched
the video but then it's uh you know
since it was 1984 I created a playlist
that was inspiration for the production
of that track so if you want to enjoy
that you can go to my Spotify account
which the best way to tell you to get to
my Spotify playlist is to go to my
Instagram
profile and then click on my Spotify
link you can't just I think that's the
link Neil I don't think I don't know
um so that you can the playlist is
called you are here inspo it's the
inspiration for the UR hear track and if
you only want to listen to one song yep
that's me yeah you can just search I
just put links certainly in and you can
in Spotify uh Automatic by The Pointer
Sisters I was so obsessed with that song
when we were making you are here so you
can check that out see how these
um 31 minutes worth of tracks made their
way into you are here there you go
that's my wreck
thanks for being my friend right I just
realized that my thanks for being my
friend thanks for being my friend I
really miss you I miss you too but I and
you know what I love you I love you too
man look at that did you see that
um but I do have something to share okay
yeah and that is that I didn't realize
that
my playlist for Locke's graduation party
last year was public
huh yeah you can make it private or you
can leave I don't really yeah I don't I
don't really use this maybe I should
make that not public maybe I should make
my whole profile not public if you want
to let us know what you think use
hashtag year biscuits and give us a call
leave us a voicemail with your thoughts
1-888
earpod one it's a pretty good playlist
I'll leave it up so it's just seven
songs okay
hey guys I just listened to the
commencement speech episode and when
link said that spreadsheets were sexy I
lost it I graduated about six months ago
with my accounting degree and
spreadsheets are sexy thank you so much
bye
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
foreign
[Music]